when I was going up I did not expect the
changes in and how narrow it gets you
can like feel the ladder wiggling and
like bouncing which is pretty scary when
I got to the top I kind of wanted to
stay up there and look around taking the
views
music
when you're in all your gear and you're
on the hose and you've got the control
over the nozzle and you're in front of
the fire you have to really communicate
with your teammates because they have to
be prepared and help back you up when
you turn the water all the way on
adrenaline is a big part of it he was
incredibly hot but once I actually got
into the real fire everything else goes
away because you're so focused on like
putting this one fire out that the heat
in all the gear and wait it just wasn't
even a factor in my mind because I was
just so focused
it was just one of the most empowering
things I've done because it challenges
me to lead a bunch of other people after
i went and experienced a week of being a
firefighter I know that this is exactly
what I want to do Mariano's I'm going
inside